it's my pleasure to welcome you today to
machine vision for cultural heritage and
natural science collections a program of
the Yale Smithsonian partnership this is
the first in what we hope to be a number
of study days that are held either in
New Haven or in DC that sort of bring
together folks not just who are on the
board or have been active in the Yale
Smithsonian partnership but who are
active in all levels of the university
and an institution respectively and the
theme we've chosen for this first study
day held here in Sterling library in the
Frankie family digital humanities
laboratory is machine vision and you can
hear this described as computer vision
you hear this described very broadly as
artificial intelligence neural networks
but we really wanted to focus on the
computational analysis of raster pixels
especially coming from an institution
like Yale which has had such a strength
of excellence in linked open data rdf
tuples open access images we really
wanted to push the boundary and explore
what could happen if we started actually
analyzing the pixels of some of our
natural heritage collections and our
cultural heritage collections as well
and that was the reason we decided to
call this machine vision for cultural
heritage in natural science collections
we knew that both institutions had
world-famous natural science museums and
institutions of research and teaching
and we also knew about the world-class
collections of art and other objects
sculpture history that are present on
both campuses in both institutions so
machine vision for cultural heritage and
natural science collections unifies
those resources which are our hundreds
of years old and it puts that together
with some techniques which are very new
which have their origins perhaps in the
mid century the 20th century but which
in the last four or five or six years
have really taken off as ways of
analyzing visual data at scale and
there's really no better way to start us
off than with our first keynote speaker
who's Rebecca decal from the data
science lab and the office of the chief
information officer at the dystonia
institution
philsie speaking today on data intensive
approaches to digitize museum
collections Rebecca thank you Peter and
thank you very much for the invitation
to be here I'm happy to talk a little
bit about some of the work we're doing
in the data science lab I will preface
it by saying I'm a trained biologist
and came into the high-performance
computing world when I was generating
genomics data as part of my dissertation
and since I arrived at the Smithsonian
after my PhD in September of 2012 as a
postdoc I started thinking about a
Smithsonian collections more broadly and
not just genomic data and so today I'll
talk to you about how we're expanding
our big data research outside of biology
but I'll start with biology so the
Smithsonian has a number of challenges
to conducting large-scale informatics
research first is there's a large
diversity of locations heterogeneous
kinds of digital data and complete
metadata and a lack of purpose-built
software tools this is particularly true
for our biology groups where most
genomics tools have been developed
around the human genome and the genomes
that Smithsonian scientists are
interested in our everything but the
human genome so everything from clams to
bacteria bacteria are a little bit
easier than than everything else to
plants to pretty much anything you can
imagine and so we're constantly on the
lookout for new tools and seeing how our
data fit into existing existing models
so this is a this isn't just a terribly
resolved photo it's a photo mosaic of an
aerial shot of them all from our
archives that I all the pixels are
filled with other aerial shots and other
building photos of the Smithsonian so
but for a machine vision workshop that
might be somewhat interesting so the
Smithsonian has 19 museums nine research
centers and a zoo most of which are on
the Smithsonian Mall but some of which
are very far-flung so we have the
Smithsonian Tropical Research Institute
in Panama which has a large group of
very accomplished evolutionary
biologists field biologists
and the Smithsonian Environmental
Research Center out in Annapolis
Maryland as well who does who do
ecologic eResearch so we're not just
collections based but research data
based as well so when we talk about
digitized collections I will keep a
Natural History focus for now just to
talk about the different kinds of
digitized data that we're talking about
photos so for example this is a photo of
a pinned fly taxonomic names specimen
records genomic sequences so have data
in GenBank geo reference localities and
label data transcribe label data as well
I would say that these are all part of
the collections object but then there
are other kinds of auxilary data that
might be part of our understanding of
this one specimen which could come from
field books where scientists who have
collected these specimens you know wrote
down some observations about it
illustrations again observations you
know what was this fly eating at the
time it was collected scientific
publications and taxonomic descriptions
so these are all these all could be
linked to these all are part of what we
know about this fly and being able to
compute across all of these data is
something that we strive for this is
just an example of what a specimen
collecting event looks like in terms of
where the data go so in the center this
is Vicki funk she's a curator of botany
and a great collaborator of mine so for
example she went out to collect this
purple very pretty flower the species is
called Center palace pasa Flores we
decided we wanted to sequence this
genome because it is a part in the
sunflower family tree that has no genome
around it so we thought it would be
interesting she collected the seeds
actually and we grew it in a greenhouse
because we needed a lot of DNA for the
kind of DNA sequencing we were doing so
from the actual specimen most of the
plant gets pressed and so you can see an
image of a pressed plant some of it goes
to a biorepository so we have its DNA
forever
you might sequence a small piece of DNA
a barcode for the fur plants those are
chloroplast genes those data go to NCBI
which is a part of NIH it's generally
called GenBank and then the specimen
information so there's a specimen record
which is in the Natural History Museum
it goes to a database called EMU and
those data are pushed to giba if the
global biodiversity information facility
so that you can go to Jebus and find
records of specimens from our museums
and also lots of other institutions the
photo might go to I dick bio so this is
just one specimen and this is all the
places that those data go to it gets way
more complicated so that's before any
research question right so that's just
like where we're going to document that
we collected this and have put it in the
places it needs to go but in order to do
the research questions Vicky's
interested in we didn't want to just
sequence the chloroplast G and we wanted
to sequence the entire genome so let's
see these are the different kind of
parts of research that we engage in so
the little museum icons at the top so we
need in order to generate the deep
learning models that Alex will talk
about later we need data from lots of
different museums we need specimen
records locality information and images
from all over the place
in order to build a phylogeny we need to
sequence in this case this is a paper
we're about to publish with 256 species
in the sunflower family we sequenced a
thousand genes for all those 256 species
so those data go to NCBI but we may in
some cases pull data from NCBI from
other institutions and then for the
genomics there's a huge amount of
software tools that we need just to
assemble and annotate the genome we make
a genome browser
closer views of these will make a genome
browser that we can share with our
collaborators where they can continue to
keep editing or annotation and then oh
that's one genome what about all the
genomes that are being generated at the
Smithsonian I'll show something that's
under construction for us which is the
Smithsonian genome hub where Smithsonian
researchers can put all their genomes in
one place and start thinking about how
to use them together so the research is
what adds a huge amount of complexity
again this is for one group of plants
there are hundreds of Smithsonian
researchers that are kind of doing
things along these lines I'll take a
short little look at genomics genomics
at the Smithsonian has been yeah and
we're generally really good at Natural
History the scientists at the
Smithsonian know their organisms they
know where to go in the field to collect
a species they know everything about it
but genomics has been a big challenge to
get all the software that researchers
need working well for their data this is
just an example of some of the tools
that you need to assemble a genome and
annotate it and a lot of times you have
to try multiple kinds of software to see
what works best for the data this is
just zooming into the genome browser
that we're creating where you have these
prediction tracks so this is just zoomed
in to a very small piece of one scaffold
and all of the gene predictions on there
which scientists can go in and say okay
I know about genes for drought tolerance
I will go and look at those and see in
detail does that look right and how can
I extract that and compare it to other
genomes that I know about so we're
trying to also we're doing this in the
cloud right now so we can easily share
it with other researchers outside the
Smithsonian so we have a high
performance computing cluster and part
of my work is helping to administer this
there are about 4,000 CPUs and 26 total
terabytes of RAM that graph the plot
just shows in the last 30 days the usage
so it is kind of up and down and it has
a weekly cycle some people don't do as
much work on the weekends which is good
but it's been really really busy we have
sixteen very high memory notes so genome
assembly often you need a terabyte or
two terabytes of RAM to assemble a
genome these are pretty beefy notes we
have many high CPU nodes as well because
most of bioinformatics software doesn't
work well and MPI frameworks it's
multi-threaded for GPUs we haven't known
with nvidia k 80s but more recently
we've my team has gotten two
workstations with NVIDIA GPU 100's and
we'll probably upgrade the GPUs and
Hydra very soon we have more than 300
genomics software packages installed on
Hydra which is an ongoing thing where
people are requesting things you know I
don't know maybe five times a week we
get requests for more software and
around 550 users in terms of Natural
History that's about I think a hundred
and eighty to Natural History Museum
users of Hydra that's a lot the Hydra
started at the Smithsonian Astrophysical
Observatory astrophysicists are way
ahead in terms of high-performance
computing but we're catching up and so
we have as many biology users as
astrophysics users which is really a big
change it's really exciting so training
is a big part as well of what we do
because we have hundreds of researchers
curators postdoctoral fellows graduate
fellows interns that all want to do this
kind of research so Smithsonian has
joined the Carpenters organization I'm
sure many of you have heard of data
software and library carpentry we joined
I think two years ago and now we have 13
trained instructors with I think 10 more
that are just finalizing their
instructor training and in the past
three years we've trained more than 300
researchers and Python our genome
analysis we started doing more ad hoc
workshops so people want to learn genome
assembly so we would do
a six-week workshop with an hour a week
talking about genome assembly but then
we realized we did a survey of Hydra
users and said what kind of workshops
are you interested in and it turned out
that you know Python are very
ground-level workshops in techniques
that they can then apply to all sorts of
research or what people were really
interested in we keep all our workshop
materials on a github page which you can
go to and we as part of our website we
have a schedule and a place where you
can request workshops as well so our
instructors would be happy to go
anywhere and give give these workshops
okay and I'll talk a little bit about
the biodiversity genome pub it's under
construction but we're really excited
about it so the plan is to have a place
that's accessible not just within the
Smithsonian but to our collaborators
where we can have all of our genome data
together so it's even hard for us at the
Smithsonian to list all the genome
projects that are going on I've tried to
get this information it's something like
150 but having one place where we can
bring all the data together and have
standards about how people are storing
that data and making sure it's backed up
and making sure it's described in a way
that makes it reusable it's really
important so we're constructing this
website which will be run through galaxy
which is a bioinformatics software an
open-source way to make reproducible
pipelines and workflows of different
tools as it wraps around any kind of
bioinformatics tool you'd want and we
hope to provide researchers the ability
to do basic analytics on their genomes
once they're sequenced and share them
with other people and hopefully allow
students and undergraduates and graduate
students to really get into genomics in
a not so intimidating way so now I'll
talk more about the computer vision
stuff sorry for the detour but I think
it's the genomics work is still pretty
exciting
so I'll give you four examples of some
of the work we're starting on I got a
the botany project is the most mature
and Alex will be talking about that this
afternoon and the other ones are which
is still experiments at this point but
pretty exciting so the Smithsonian
digitization program office has started
a program in the Natural History Museum
to digitize or generate images and
transcriptions of the labels for all the
botanical specimens in the herbarium of
which there are five million so there's
this conveyor belt that runs eight hours
a day and generates thousands of images
per day I don't know exactly I think
there are three million at this point
that are completed and as a first step a
number of years two and a half years ago
or so we thought okay let's see if we
can train deep learning models to detect
to classify and to detect mercury
staining and why mercury staining well
botanist used to preserve their
specimens with Mercury to keep pests
away and we know that that now that
that's not a great thing to have
alongside people and you can see the
specimen on the left has been stained
with mercury and over the years the
mercury crystallizes out and so it's
very visible to the human eye but it's
not generally part of the metadata for
the specimen so on sometimes there's a
little poison stamp on some of them
we're not exactly sure if that directly
correlates to whether it is recurring or
not or it could mean something else but
we can see it it's not part of the
metadata so I thought we thought an
interesting question was well can the
computer see it and can we then point
out hotspots in the collection that
might be where some remediation might be
required they put the mercury stay in
specimens that they know about into
special folders but no one person can
open five million folders to check the
rest of them and then family ID these
are two different families of fern
allies they're quite similar to
earng biologists such as myself and we
thought we would do a very simple binary
classification problem can we tell these
apart with good accuracy and in video
helped us with this first pilot as well
so these are just a confusion matrices
showing for each model that we built the
the number this is just the the test set
so we I should have mentioned earlier
that we had to manually find a training
set of mercury stained specimens so it
was a lot of hours of going through
images and we pulled we had a set of
10,000 that were mercury stained in
10,000 that were clean that we've
labeled by hand and the confusion matrix
shows just for a test set which of the
stained and unstained actual images were
predicted to be stained and on stain so
you would hope that the diagonal going
this way would be a hundred percent it's
not a hundred percent but the number of
its did very well so the percentages in
the 90s for both the family
identification and the mercury staining
so we're really excited about the fact
that this worked and you will hear
what's next for botany and a very very
we've expanded this greatly this
afternoon so I won't talk any more about
that no I will talk a little bit about
bumblebees as well you may say like
that's pretty random my answer Boas but
because the digitisation program office
has targeted specific collections we've
kind of gone with where the data are
right now and so the bumblebee project
was to photograph all the specimens of
bumblebees around 45,000 bumble bees are
all part of the same genus bombas and so
all of these are photographed this is
just examples of how the photos look
they're generally just a lateral view
some of them are a dorsal view the
labels are
are as well in the in the image and I
when I looked at these I thought I don't
I can't tell these apart at all I I
don't know if this is going to work
entomologists might say well you know
the way we tell these apart is very
specific banding patterns and genitalia
like well we can't really see that in
these images very well so I don't I
don't know but we'll give it a try and
the other interesting part of this
project is the transcription was
crowd-sourced through the tourists
Smithsonian transcription Center which
is where volunteers go online and can
transcribe label data which is a really
great way to get people involved in in
real research and so all of our labels
we have been transcribed data so we
didn't really have to go through and
make a training set ourselves the
interesting thing is that about more
than 10,000 were unidentified and I
talked to the bee curator at Natural
History and he said no that can't be
that can't be and then we opened the
cabinets and said yeah 10,000 of these
are unidentified so the idea of being
that if our model can classify two
species pretty well we could at least
have estimates of what the other
unidentified bees are we may not be able
to put that directly back into the
collections system but we can at least
tell researchers coming in these you
might also be interested in these
specimens because we think there are
this species so this didn't show up
super well but we trained two models so
far a sub genus model there are 15
sub-genre of bombas that we have in our
data set and the overall accuracy is
above 93 percent and for the species
model this was really interesting we're
still just starting out working with
this but there's 178 species and some of
them have ten images or so and so I've
thrown them all in even though those are
very small amounts of data and it's
still overall very accurate so the next
steps are to talk to the bee curator in
more detail about whether any of the
things that are more often confused
our actual taxonomic issues that are
either mislabeled in the data or they
are very very closely related and we're
also just just starting to experiment
with the activation heat maps that we
can generate from the models that allow
us to look at which pixels are activated
in the model and start understanding you
know what the model is look at looking
at in the B and I think success in this
area will be really important to
convincing the biologist that is not
just a black box that we're actually you
know where the model is seeing the same
kinds of characters that you're looking
at in your microscope and it's not so
scary so now I'll talk a little bit
about a project we're really just
starting but the Smithsonian
conservation biology Institute Center
for conservation and sustainability they
work with oil companies mostly to look
at impacts of installing pipelines
mostly in the Amazon and with this
project there is a company that's
looking to install this flexible
pipeline and they are looking to look at
baseline biodiversity before during and
after the installation and so they've
traditionally used camera traps and
people actually catching catching
animals taking DNA but we're trying a
new approach where fishermen have been
given cameras I'm given training into
how to photograph fish that they catch
we're getting the images and now we will
start training a model let's see if we
can identify fish to species that are
and as as the pipeline gets installed we
can have a time series hopefully of what
the communities look like before during
and after at different time points and
then figure out what what impacts the
pipeline has on fish communities that's
really exciting because it has
real-world impact
and then I'll talk briefly about two
other collaborations we're working on
the United States Holocaust Memorial
Museum approached us because they have
lots of digital data mostly scans over
the project we're talking about as scans
of documents without any metadata about
them just what archive they come from so
we are currently looking for a postdoc
to lead this project to first just start
understanding more about the kinds of
documents that they have so they have a
lot of diaries letters lists birth
certificates marriage certificates just
all sorts of archival data around the
time that the Holocaust was happening
and making it more discoverable for
researchers that come to their museum to
do research and in terms of the digital
data don't know where to start so we're
hoping to make a dent in that and the
Smithsonian American Women's History
Initiative is another pan Smithsonian
initiative that started last year with a
large digital component and we're hoping
to contribute by training machine
learning models to find again have a
better baseline data about how women
have been involved in the Smithsonian
over time both in collecting objects as
well as producing artworks and we're you
know where are the women in the
Smithsonian what have what stories have
we missed in the last hundred 50 years
so to that end we've have some
preliminary data from Smithsonian
archives where we're looking at official
Smithsonian photographer images we're
generally they go through and identify
people that let's say for example this
is an example of a photo they're really
just interesting on a human level to
look at the photos of what was going on
in the 1970s in this case the women are
all identified but there are many many
thousands of images where people aren't
identified and in group portraits more
often men are identified and women are
left out for whatever reason so we're
hoping to first get a survey of
you know how many times women that are
labeled in these images show up in other
images that aren't labeled and to start
getting some baseline data about that
here are just some examples and then
this is kind of there are lots of group
or trips like these where it's from a
meeting or from something else and
people aren't labeled but maybe we can
start making connections between people
where we have images where we know where
they are and also finding completely
outside of knowing who they are
clustering clustering faces as well in
in the official photographs to try to
find people who maybe haven't been
described we don't have their story
represented in any Smithsonian
collection or metadata but maybe we can
start elevating their stories so the
takeaways are we've really only just
started this work there's so much to do
and right now every sorry the type of
every application of machine learning is
a research project given our diverse and
incomplete unique data and so I make
another photo mosaic of the castle with
all the portrait data that I've gotten
from archives so portraits of
Smithsonian people where we know the
people but I keep thinking you know what
who are we missing when we're talking
about who has kind of built the
Smithsonian and so hoping that we can
use these tools to elevate new stories
that better represent the people who
actually visit the Smithsonian and so
here's my my team and I this work would
not happen without them if you have from
from the left my postdoc Marion sue Shia
Mike Trishna and Alex white Alex will be
talking later our partners across the
Smithsonian again this work wouldn't be
possible without all the other some
Sounion units and funding the
Smithsonian Women's Committee the almost
of the provost and office of the CIO so
thanks
[Applause]
[Music]